i actually call this the wisdom practice
which is i i'm sitting typically on my
mat outside
in the morning i go to my observer mind
i look down at my ego self and i just
run through
ego anger at others anger at myself
resentment despair
unresolved grief uh envy guilt
shame just i run across the the you know
what i'll call the
the dirty dozen you know whatever they
are and
when i discover one it's as if it it's
as if it
perks up it says yeah i'm i'm active
today
so then i want to go in and find out so
for example this is something i teach
anger almost always means a frustrated
need expectation entitlement or demand
right the n-e-e-d
acronym that's the n-e-e-d acronym
everybody who studies with me has to
know this chapter and verse
okay so if i'm upset with somebody it's
not what they did
is they they disappointed my need
so i want to i want to stop being
mesmerized by their deeds
and focus on my needs
right now here's what happens when you
focus on your needs your anger goes down
90
because you're not transfixed by
somebody else's behavior so people say
well what about what they did i said
we'll get to them later
but is this not all rooted two things
first is this not all rooted in in
expectations around outcomes sure
there's
that and do these are are not these
all these emotions really all rooted in
fear
like fear is the anteceded emotion from
which all of these other
sort of yeah i'm not convinced of that
sometimes it's domination
and sometimes aggressive dominant people
are not motivated by fear they're just
motivated by domination
and when they don't get what is that
what does that urge towards domination
come from does
it it's this idea that somebody else if
somebody else gets it i can't
then you know i think there's a that in
the so-called alpha
being they're not motivated i fear
they really ultimately want domination
and
extinguish anybody who stands in their
way it's a type of person
now another person says please stop
that's fear
the person is how dare you disobey me
they're not motivated by
fear i think i think i think aggression
and domination are pretty pure as
emotions
i don't i'm i could be wrong here but i
don't think fear is an antecedent
emotion
i think aggression and dominance
over others is primary
um i could be wrong but um
you know that there are times like i
still say i find myself upset
you know like let's say i've asked my
kids to do something like super clear
rational and they just don't do it
and i feel angry like i asked you to do
something
clear rational i was you know
when and they just decided not to so i
see the i see the anger
there's no fear there i just don't like
being disobeyed
but i don't want to be an angry guy okay
so i have a neat expectation entitlement
demand that my
child chose not to uh
um to perform now i have to look and so
my path is um
was my need moral rational
and useful and when i go to moral
rational and useful
from a rational perspective that's part
of the dance of parents and children
is children etching out independence by
disobedience
it's not personal it's part of healthy
ego development of a child
so if i respond with anger i'm stunting
their growth i'm not helping anybody
so i calm myself down i say okay say
can i talk to you a minute sure i said
so i asked to do this yeah dad i'm sorry
it's not about sorry now because i have
my coach hat and i have my authority hat
this is the coach app
i want you to look inside yourself and i
want you to find the meaning of the
disobedience see i found the meaning of
my anger
but i'm gonna get rid of it because what
replaces the anger is my calling as a
parent
which is to parent the soul of my child
so now i'm calm and i say okay this is
actually
a soul moment so my child says okay i'm
sorry i said
sorry is for next right now i want you
to ask
why that was meaningful to you to
disobey me
they say i don't know i say i have time
i'm just imagining how this would play
out with my kids they'd be try it
leave me alone like no try try it i've
been doing it ever since they were seven
or eight years old and they do something
and you say what happened in your inner
life
where that decision made sense
they say i don't know i said i know you
don't know and
and and that's what you that's what it
means to be a child in this family
because your answer is let me think or
i'll look it up that's something you're
all trained
you can say let me think or i'll look it
up after you say i don't know
[Music]
you